ANYWAY.
>> Sean: I USED TO JOKE ABOUT
IT BUT IT'S NOT FUNNY.
ONE MORE QUESTION, DOES ANYONE
THINK PUTIN WOULD BE AMASSING
100,000 PLUS TROOPS ON THE
BORDER WITH UKRAINE, THREATENING
WAR IF DONALD TRUMP WERE STILL
IN OFFICE?
I DOUBT THAT WOULD BE HAPPENING,
NOR DO I THINK HE WOULD'VE
GOTTEN A WAIVER ON THE PIPELINE.
THEN AGAIN THE TRUMP FAMILY
NEVER MADE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WITH RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS THE WAY
THE BIDEN FAMILY DID.
SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM MET WITH
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, HE JOINS
US NOW WITH MORE.
I SEE THAT AD AND I'LL BE HONEST
I THINK THE OBSERVATION OF YOUR
COLLEAGUE'S NOT TOO FAR OFF AND
THAT IS MAYBE WE SHOULD KEEP
THEM AWAY FROM CAMERAS AND
MICROPHONES BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
BAD.
>> A NEWS CONFERENCE WAS A
DISASTER ON MULTIPLE LEVELS BUT
IT'S NOT THE NEWS CONFERENCE,
HE'S BEEN ON THE WORLD STAGE FOR
40 YEARS.
HE WAS IN CHARGE OF THE UKRAINE
PORTFOLIO UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
EVERYBODY IN THE UKRAINE
UNDERSTANDS JOE BIDEN DIDN'T
REALIZE HIS OWN SON WAS SERVING
ON THE BOARD OF THE MOST CORRUPT
GAS COMPANY IN THE WORLD.
I TALKED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
ABOUT THIS, HE'S FLOORED LIKE I
AM ON A CERTAIN LEVEL WE ALL
WANT TO PULL FOR THE PRESIDENT
THAT WE CAN DO BETTER WITH
COVID, WE CAN MAKE THE WORLD A
SAFER PLACE.
PUTIN REALIZES UNDER BIDEN HE
CAN INVADE UKRAINE AND GET AWAY
WITH IT, UNDER TRUMP HE COULD
NOT INVADE UKRAINE AND GET AWAY
WITH IT.
HERE'S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
TO ME TODAY THAT WAS PRETTY
STUNNING AND APPROPRIATE.
HE SAID PUTIN IS REALIZING THAT
BIDEN IS WEAK BUT HE DOESN'T
REALIZE THAT BIDEN WON'T BE
AROUND IN 2024.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID TODAY IF
THEY INVADE UKRAINE, IT WILL
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANY
FUTURE PRESIDENT TO HAVE A
NORMAL RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA,
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS A PRETTY
WISE OBSERVATION.
>> Sean: I'M LOOKING AT WHAT
LOOKS LIKE A BAND-AID ON YOUR
NOSE, HE DIDN'T GIVE YOU A POP
IN THE NOSED, DID HE?
>> THAT'S BERNIE SANDERS.
>> HE DIDN'T HIT YOU WITH A GOLF
BALL?
HE'S RIGHT IN HIS OBSERVATIONS
AND JOE BIDEN IS A DISASTER.
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE OUT RUSSIA,
TO ME IT'S EASY AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD FOR OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AND THAT IS
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AND IT'S
ALSO GOOD TO STOP THE 40 YEAR
HIGH IN INFLATION.
EVERY PRICE OF EVERY ITEM WE BUY
WILL GO DOWN BECAUSE IT WILL
COST LESS TO SHIP IT AND WE'LL
PAY LESS OF THE PUMP, LESS TO
HEAT OUR HOMES AND THAT WOULD BE
ONE WAY OUT.
IF I WANT TO TAKE ON CHINA AND
STOP THEIR TERRITORIAL AMBITIONS
WITH TAIWAN, I WOULD FORM A
COALITION AND STOP ALL IMPORTING
FROM THAT WILL SHUT DOWN THEM
QUICK AS WELL, THAT IS BOTH OF
THEIR ECONOMIES HANGING IN THE
BALANCE.
>> RUSSIA IS EXPOSED AS A GAS
STATION PARADING AS A COUNTRY,
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE FOR US
WEAKENS RUSSIA.
THE DAY THAT AMERICA DOESN'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE MIDEAST
IN TERMS OF OIL AND GAS IS A
GREAT DAY.
CHINA IS VERY MUCH CONNECTED TO
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY AND TRUMP
THREATEN TO PUT TARIFFS ON
CHINESE PRODUCTS, THEY CHANGED
WHEN TRUMP TOLD MEXICO IF YOU
DON'T HELP ME SECURE OUR BORDER
I WILL PUT TARIFFS ON YOUR
PRODUCTS COMING OUT OF MEXICO,
THEY CHANGED, STRENGTH WORKS,
WEAKNESS DOESN'T, HERE IS MY
MESSAGE TO PRESIDENT BIDEN, YOU
CLAIM NO REPUBLICAN WANTS TO
HELP YOU, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU'VE GOT TO DO THINGS WE CAN
HELP YOU WITH.
WHY DON'T WE PUT SANCTIONS ON
RUSSIA NOW FOR THE BUILDUP, NOT
THE INVASION.
LET'S PUNISH PUTIN NOW AND WHY
DON'T WE DO A LEND-LEASE BILL
LIKE SENATOR CORNYN HAS DOING
FOR THE UKRAINIANS WHAT THEY DID
FOR THE BRITISH IN THE EARLY
STAGES OF WORLD WAR II, ENDLESS
WEAPONS TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE A
BUNCH OF DEAD RUSSIANS IF YOU
INVADE UKRAINE.
BIDEN CANNOT ADJUST HIS POLICIES
ON ENERGY, CAN'T ADJUST HIS
POLICIES ON BORDERS BECAUSE THE
LEFT -- HE CAN ADJUST HIS